the harvest from this Palestinian farm
in the Jordan Valley was supposed to
make its way into the Israeli market but
not anymore
Israel's banning all agricultural
produce from the occupied West Bank
after a decision by Palestinian
officials to cut down on some Israeli
imports
samer saw after owns around 25 acres of
land and plants them with zucchinis and
cucumbers
he says the Israeli ban is going to have
a devastating effect on his business if
we were going to make some money out of
it now after the ban we weren't will
hardly be able to cover our running
costs farming is the main source of
income for Palestinians living in the
Jordan Valley they've been selling
vegetables to Israel for decades this is
one of the main markets for fresh
produce in the occupied West Bank and
that has pushed prices down on Wednesday
the Palestinian government responded to
the Israeli ban by barring some Israeli
products from entering the West Bank
this is not the first economic rattle
between the two sides but it's different
now because the Palestinian government
says it wants to limit dependency on the
Israeli economy it started with a pilot
project in October to cut down imports
of Israeli cuffs and buy them from other
countries instead Israeli cattle raisers
say that the ban violates signed
agreements between Israel and the
Palestinian Authority we are dependent
on the Palestinian market Palestinian
talk and direct import of calls from
abroad but they don't have enough thatch
and haste spaces which are the basic
food of the animals Palestinians import
three times more from Israel than they
export to it which analysts say could
make any trade war between the two very
one-sided as Israel controls all borders
and crossings it has the final say in
the flow of goods and services for
example it can prevent any foreign goods
from entering the Palestinian market
they control more important sectors as
such as the energy sector fuel and
foreign currency with years of
occupation and blockade severely
weakening the Palestinian economy many
believe they may be forced to back down
before the Israelis do neither ibrahim
al Jazeera the occupied West Bank